- I feel like you can
totally wear this shirt
all commando and like no nips are showing.
This is the quality of the
shirt that you're getting.
- Nip-less.
- Nipple-less.
(upbeat tune)
- Okay.
- This is definitely a white dress shirt.
- Well no duh, Brenden.
- Nailed it. Nailed it.
- So off the bat you
can see that it has like
really nice material.
There's like some kind of pattern
onto it
- Textured, yeah.
- Versus just like a
plain white dress shirt.
- It's pretty thick.
- It's slim fit.
- But you can get cheap slim fits,
I've gotten $12 slime fits.
- The texture is like really soft
and you don't get this for cheap.
- You know how sometimes
you get a white dress shirt
and it's almost like see through?
- It's like that thin lin--
- Yeah.
- This is better than that.
- I mean is there a place
to put a cuff link? No.
- I would say this shirt is $55.
- I'm gonna say this shirt is $75.
- I'm gonna guess retail this is $39.99.
- I'm just gonna agree with you,
$39.99 sounds like a solid price for this.
- $19.99.
- I say $30.
$19.99 you don't get this texture.
- Ooh, Oh.
- So I say $30 for this one.
$20.
(bell dinging)
- $79?
- Oh whoa whoa.
- I would not pay $79 for this.
- You know just from looking at it
and feeling how it feels,
I can automatically tell
that this is probably $20.
- Yeah this has the feel of like
American Eagle, like that type.
Like casual, it's like a
casual white shirt dress shirt.
- It's like rough.
- It is.
I don't know if I could
call this a dress shirt.
Usually for me if it's a dress shirt
I could put on a blazer
or I could put on some
kind of accent to it.
- I like this shirt.
It's nice and thick.
- It's one where you don't need to iron it
'cause the wrinkly part of
it is like part of the style.
- This is the white dress
shirt you see dudes wear
at like a wedding or something
where it's like, that guy
doesn't have a nice dress shirt.
He's wearing his one white shirt.
It's always kind of wrinkly.
It's this shirt.
- So this is Brenden's shirt.
- This is my shirt.
This is the one I would have.
- I would guess $14.99.
- $25.
- I would guess this shirt is $25.
- Agreed.
- I think I'm going to say $30.
- I'm gonna guess that this is Old Navy
and put it at $20.
(bell dinging)
- Woo!
- Nice.
- This has to be Van Heusen.
- Yeah, Van Heusen is like
usually the $12 ones I buy.
This is very Van Heusen-y looking.
- The buttons on this one
are actually like white and not ivory.
Nicer buttons means it's
actually a nicer shirt.
- This does have like the soft texture
that we saw in the first one.
And also, the cuffs.
The cuffs are like really nice and sturdy.
- This is pretty see-through, I think.
- This is definitely
sold at an outlet mall.
- It's definitely a shirt
that is going to cost a little bit more
for like the way the cuff is,
I feel like the way the collar is.
I'd say $79.
- I'm gonna say $85.
- I mean I can pretty
confidently call this one $15.
- I'm gonna say $24.97.
- I feel like it's like $80 bucks.
- Or $60.
- I wanna say this is $45.
- Oh I say $45, too!
(bell dinging)
- Oh.
- This feels like very synthetic.
This doesn't feel like cotton to me.
- It's like a little bit see-through.
You can see your nips through it.
- All the nipples can
be seen through here.
- This feels like the shirt that you get
when you rent your prom tux.
- Yes, absolutely.
- It's more fitted.
- Yeah, what does that mean?
- So when you tuck it into your pants,
it's not gonna like muffin top you.
- It's probably something
that's easily accessible for everybody.
- And the fabric is a
little bit more stretchy.
Like feel the stretchiness of it.
- Whoa it's so stretchy.
What the heck?
- I guess maybe like $20.
- I was gonna say $20, but I want,
- I'm gonna say $19.
- Just to be different, Brenden?
- Mm-hmm.
- I didn't get my $14.99 before,
I'm throwing my $14.99 on this one.
- I'm gonna high ball this at $59.99.
- $12.99.
- I'm gonna say $60.
(bell dinging)
- Oh!
- Geez.
- Shut up!
This is $135?
I will say, though,
I don't knock on the higher priced shirts
just because I do feel
like it's an investment
and if you're willing to invest,
it'll last you longer.
- You could get an Airbnb in Maui
for the price of some of these shirts.
- [Sergio] You could live
without a shirt in Maui.
- That's what I would do.
Vacation more, shop less.